[Music]
depending on if you're Roman numeral
game is up to scratch Final Fantasy XV
is here or should I say Final Fantasy 15
is here but with every addition to the
franchise come speculation intrigue and
misinformation we here at PlayStation
grenade have your back here are 10
things you should know about Final
Fantasy 15 although the final fantasy
games have the same fundamental approach
they do not relate to one another on a
narrative level therefore no you don't
need to play Final Fantasy 1 through 14
to understand this game you can miss
them all if you like well maybe go back
and play seven because that was bloody
brilliant but basically this game is for
veterans and newcomers alike so throw
yourself into it speaking of the
narrative this game is based around four
characters noctis ignis gladiolus and
prompt or I hope I'm pronouncing those
right yes they do look like a.j pop boy
band but it's a little more graphic than
that two warring nations have finally
decided to lay down their weapons and
the embodiment of this armistice comes
in the shape of your marriage one side
put forward a prince the other side put
forward a princess in the hope that they
will one day rule this happy kingdom
together of course things don't go to
plan but this is a spoiler free zone so
let's move on many people run away from
the final fantasy games due to the
turn-based fighting but don't fear my
produced because Final Fantasy 15 now
uses real-time combat wail about to your
heart's content upload offensive you now
have everything at your fingertips as
quickly as you can dream it your
character will do it the trend of truly
open world games has been brought into
Final Fantasy meaning you can go
anywhere you like and pursue the
narrative or locate side missions from
the outset think of it similarly to
fallout 4 did you try and find Sean or
did you help out the local inhabitants
instead when you do decide to view the
world in your own time you can use your
trusty ish automobile if you want to
walk just spread your legs if not jump
in and take the weight off you can drive
manually or use the auto drive function
now just taking those gorgeous views you
can't have a final fantasy game without
a little magic if you have played
previous installments of the final
fantasy series magic feels very similar
to other iterations
but if you're new to it let me quickly
run through things there are three
elemental magic type similar to Pokemon
starters or destiny damage types in
Final Fantasy 15 you have fire ice and
lightning these can be used individually
or as part of a combo I walk going to
any more deaths as it would confuse you
and it would definitely confuse me but
I'm certain the game will integrate a
tutorial seamlessly there are indeed
weapon types to get to grips with in
Final Fantasy 15 from small daggers to
two hundred swords from shields to guns
and even axes if you have a preferred
battle strategy the game will
accommodate it the evolution of weapons
has been hinted at two but any more
information would make this a spoiler so
let's move on the best RPGs include a
leveling system that's role-playing game
not rocket propelled grenade by the way
as in pretty much all I pg's the more
your character levels the heavier your
attacks and the stronger your defense so
don't skip content or you may regret it
later oh also you'll be playing as four
characters for large parts of the game
so remember to upgrade all your
characters as you are only strong as
your weakest link I suggested earlier
the game is for newbies and franchise
veterans so if you're looking for choco
balls yes they are here hanqing for some
Phoenix down yep is here too don't worry
if that sounds like gibberish you'll
soon be speaking Final Fantasy could in
no time at all finally a season pass has
been confirmed with six expansions an
episode pack for each of the main
characters are booster pack and one more
unconfirmed final episode so that's our
list of 10 things you should know about
Final Fantasy 15 at this point I was
going to ask you what your favorite
Final Fantasy game is but I know its
final fantasy 7 so I'll ask you who your
favorite character is instead mine is
Barrett oh what a man and please do me a
favor and like and subscribe to put a
smile on this fat man's face i am adam
for playstation grenade and i'll see you
next time
[Music]